[Music]
this week we're talking about footwork
so I'm Christopher Hein from Aikido
Fresno and this is our footwork week so
we're talking about footwork today we're
going to talk a little bit about a drill
to help you improve your footwork so
this is part of the live training ideas
in Aikido and so how can we lie in a
live fashion train our footwork it's
very important than IQ know that when
you're learning to stand in your rope oh
no c'mon you're hung me stance that you
can spontaneously move at the drop of a
hat and that you're positioned right
your weights in the right place and you
know how to do all the basic footwork
from that position so this drill is
gonna help you move through basic
footwork in a spontaneous way so we're
really gonna try and shock your
unconscious mind a little bit here and
get you moving right so I'm going to get
Josh in my out here and we're gonna work
on some spontaneous forward drills
okay so we're gonna talk about a set of
fundamental footwork drills to build
spontaneous footwork so remember we just
have our basic four movements we're
gonna do a sukiyaki and au Miyaichi 10
con or a chi chi's those are our basic
movements you get a set of tools so at
the dojo I use these sticks to give them
an auditory response so they can hear
that to have an immediate response and I
use to click for out of you Miyaichi and
one click for sukiyaki and then I
verbally tell them either tin con or Tai
Chi ah sh t when we do that I sometimes
will also add eating meat n con right so
meaning that they're gonna do a two-step
or a you Miyaichi 10 con right so this
is basically how the drill goes 10 con
Tai Chi
10 con - okay so that's the basic idea
of the drill now what's important in
this drill is the students should be
learning to not go without a command so
if there's no command they shouldn't go
they should also try not to guess what's
going to happen so their mind should be
currently in the moment always so if I
haven't given them instruction then
they're not gonna do anything and
they're always gonna do the instruction
I give now I can make this much more
challenging as I've changed the speed or
tempo sometimes I can give them a set of
the same thing over and over and over
and then change that set so I can do
lots of things to mess with them which
is what I want to do so I want to give
them a really hard time so it forces
them to stay in the moment now above all
that they want to make sure they're
always resetting their rocoto combined
with their weight forward so it's going
to be weight forward when they're doing
this and that means that they can move
freely into any of those four steps any
time it happens now I'm gonna try and
give them a little bit of a hard time to
show you guys and let's see what we can
do with them here now if I give a long
pause they should be making sure they
don't change their
stance their stance should always be
exactly the same 10 con 10 con Chi Chi
achi 10 coq10 con su ya see now I threw
one in their form
rejection was my mistake but it's great
because you see what they do right so so
that wasn't what I'm saying I do but
they should be able to go home so yes
you know what that is and immediately do
Tsuyoshi so I can mess with them in all
kinds of ways now this is good practice
for them because it's giving them a
little bit of stress to work with
fundamental footwork now remember when
you're adding live drills to your
practice you want to boost up the stress
slowly right so they should be able to
have good core set of skills and then
develop that core set of skills 10
o'clock 10 o'clock
tyshee action 10 con 10 o'clock thank
you thank you
[Music]
10 o'clock 10 o'clock sexy action
excellent all right good times I was
trying to get them to a point where they
would start to make mistakes now it's
good to understand that when you're
doing this if you make a mistake you
need to learn to instantly let that go
this is good training for everything
else you're gonna do an Aikido because
if you hold on to a mistake that means
you're just gonna keep having problems
right your brain is like a computer you
can only process so much and so if
you're spinning some of your processing
power going oh I made a mistake go on
stupid oh that's bad on behind
that's just costing you a bill
processing power that you can use for
something that you need to so in a
high-stress situation where someone's
trying to attack you you need to be able
to immediately drop mistakes I made a
mistake I drop it you can analyze your
mistakes later in the moment is not the
time to do that so this is a really good
drill to begin to work with a little bit
of live practice in your footwork once
the students can make really good live
practice like this then they can start
to move on to other skills they need to
be able to consistently use the footwork
correctly and then be able to do it in a
spontaneous fashion so this is one of
the basic drills we use for training
footwork I'm Christopher Hein thanks for
watching